[Music]
straight ahead
all on crime daily a shocking
whistleblower complaint
of forced medical procedures on women at
a federal detention center
experts say it's completely illegal i
don't know that anyone can be
compensated for the loss of their
ability to
have children plus attorneys for one of
the cops
accused of killing george floyd want to
make it easier to kick people off the
jury pool
and with guns drawn local state and
federal agents rescue missing children
it's just a great time for law
enforcement up something i'm very very
proud of here in georgia
authorities take us inside the operation
on lawn crime daily
where we cover court cases from coast to
coast
[Music]
and welcome everyone i'm erin keller
along with brian buckmeyer and terry
austin
attorneys for one of the former police
officers accused of playing a role in
the alleged murder of george floyd
are asking a judge to give them the
chance to kick more people off the jury
once the case goes to trial
attorneys for defendant j alexander king
say each defendant should have
10 so-called peremptory challenges but
in no case less than a minimum of five
each
the rules say the defense generally
receives five strikes once the panel is
seated but
all four defendants could legally be
forced to share
in this case the number of defendants
means each side might only get
one chance to strike one juror each
without cause
and maybe they'd have to agree on the
fifth final strike
prosecutors meanwhile get three strikes
let's jump in analysis now terry austin
trials are about fairness and the
process of selecting a panel
and then allowing each side prosecutors
and the defense to
deselect a few people for any reason
whatsoever
it's mathematically simple but it raises
a lot of questions about
who is getting kicked off the panel is
the defense trying to get
more strikes to maybe hypothetically for
instance
kick black lives matter people off the
panel well i do
think that the defense is trying to take
advantage of the situation if normally
the whole defense
side would get five asking for ten each
i think is excessive
so we should see some sort of compromise
here
and i think the attorney for officer
king is asking for too much and maybe we
should have
you know somewhere in between 5 and 10
total
yeah i mean if you get 10 each we're
talking about 40 strikes brian it would
be
very difficult to seat the jury walk us
through the rest of the numbers
here brian minnesota generally allows
five strikes
on the defense side here in new york the
number is very different yeah exactly so
in new york if you're
faced with an a felony you get 20
preemptory strikes
uh and you get two more for alternates
if you're facing a b or c
felony b felonies are like attempted
murder while a's are murders
you get 15 and two for alternates now
exactly like they do in minnesota and in
new york
those peremptory challenges are shared
now i understand that
five per that group of four is very low
but they've got to ask for a high number
knowing that the prosecutor's gonna come
back
and kind of even it out because they've
got to share those numbers overall
terry is this a matter of fairness for
the defendants to get a higher number of
strikes do you agree with brian
i do because i think each of them might
have different reasons for eliminating a
juror so they should get some additional
strikes but
not as many as 10 each moving on now it
appears a plea deal which started nearly
a year ago remains in the works for a
suspended illinois attorney accused of
murdering
his five-year-old son the mother of the
slain boy pleaded guilty to beating her
son to death on april 14
2019. prosecutors claim andrew friend
senior
moved the boy's body and buried him in a
shallow grave
but on a 9-1-1 call placed four days
after the alleged murder
friend claimed his son was missing
and when was last time last night
probably 9 30
when he went to bed
are you the father yes
you know where you might have went no
um we've canvassed the neighborhood yeah
i went to the local park
local gas station down here where we
sometimes take them to buy
treats i spoke with the assistant
principal over there at the school where
the park is
and they they haven't seen kim or
any other child i have no idea where he
would be
friend appeared in court to reach an
agreement in the long awaited plea deal
but it looks like his case will be
extended
a little bit longer
a brief very brief 402 conference this
morning
to inform the court would help us end a
resolution
well
is there a negotiation in this case yes
state
we believe so all right if there's not a
negotiation in the case i'll see you in
december yeah no there's a negotiation
all right so what date you want to set
it for a negotiated plea friday
we'd ask for friday we'll give mr friend
two telephone calls to communicate with
his attorney
and we'll see everybody back here
september 18
1 30 for negotiated plea
terry and brian i want to ask what you
think about this one brian the boy's
mother pleaded guilty and is serving 35
years she's 37 years old now so she
might get out of prison in her 70s
relatives were not happy with that deal
they wanted a higher sentence for the
mother
but oftentimes judges agree to deals if
defendants admit their conduct so
could this defendant also be facing some
kind of a deal like that
absolutely this defendant's going to be
taking some sort of a plea deal to avoid
some of the stronger penalties that
would come
from going to trial now what that's
going to be we're not quite sure
but you've got to look at the elements
and the participation in the soul you've
got to remember this father made a 9-1-1
call about a lost child when in fact he
knew exactly where that child was and he
put the community through a lot of pain
and suffering he'll be interesting to
see what he pleads guilty to down the
road
that call damaging evidence right there
terry so the judge told the boy's mother
her actions were quote inhumane
repulsive and frankly shocking but
some of the case was built on the
father's statements to the authorities
about the mother
abusing the boy so should the father
get a better deal on friday i suppose
you could argue that he could get a
better deal because he was cooperating
and he was
telling the authorities what the mother
did but on the other hand as brian
said he misled the authorities and you
can also
argue he stood by why his son was being
abused
and his son was murdered and he also
helped bury the body so
you know the punishment should be
significant we'll be watching that plea
hearing when it actually happens and
still ahead on law and crime daily
a nurse blowing the lid on medical
procedures at a federal detention center
allegations of mass hysterectomies and
the whistleblower
complaint behind it and later on
officers use old techniques and new
technology to track down
39 missing children we go inside the
operation
right here on lawn crime daily
and now to a story which went viral this
week on law and crime.com
a nurse at a federal immigration
detention center in georgia has accused
a gynecologist
of sterilizing detained women without
their consent
according to court papers ice officials
transferred women to an outside
gynecologist named mahendra amen
who was allegedly called the uterus
collector
the nurse claims that women were often
confused when asked to explain
why they were given a hysterectomy on
crime daily's brian buckmeyer spoke
to a legal and policy director at an
advocacy group
to separate separate out rather who
legally is to blame here brian
yeah so sarah ainsworth is the legal
director of the group called if
when how the doctor accused of
performing the hysterectomies
isn't a private practice but ainsworth
told me there's a potential to bring a
lawsuit against both the individual
doctor
and ice it is
frequently the case that people who are
incarcerated who experience
poor care in either private or state
prisons
or in federal prison people who
experience
human rights abuses and poor care and
ice detention centers
have a complaint against the agency
that is responsible for employing this
person even if
this person carried out these acts
unbeknownst to
ice but i think that's unlikely in the
circumstance given the fact that we're
talking about
we have a whistleblower we have numerous
people complaining
i think it's um it's going to be harder
for
a state agency to claim that they had no
knowledge and that this was done without
their consent
in this circumstance while i haven't
seen um the reports yet because you're
just getting them and i'm just hearing
them
it's not at all surprising to me that to
learn that
a doctor has continued to provide care
despite complaints
despite shoddycare and that ice
detention centers have done nothing
to protect the people who are detained
from this kind of practice
okay brian so let's talk about the legal
issues here even if you are
incarcerated you have rights and you
have to consent to a procedure like this
unless for instance in the rare example
of someone being
unconscious who needs a life-saving
procedure absolutely even when you're
incarcerated you still have first
fifth sixth eighth 14th amendments and
that's probably what's going to apply
here
it's also an issue of proper consent
whether or not they were informed
in a language that they understand to be
able to make an intelligent decision as
to whether or not to have these
hysterectomies
and based on the whistleblower's
information they did not okay terry so
the same doctor was part of an
investigation in 2015.
the legal history of forced
sterilization is on the books already
it's rocky the supreme court actually
allowed
it at one point but then in a case
called skinner v oklahoma they struck
down a law which required
repeat offenders to be sterilized is
this case a lot more like skinner in
your opinion
well you know the supreme court in
skinner they knocked down
the sterilization that was compulsory
that if it related to habitual criminals
only
and not if it was you know equally
applied so they didn't say you can't use
it it does sound a little bit like an
eye for an
eye but they said if you do use it you
must
make sure that it is applied equally not
just to criminal
who have been habitual uh you know
violators of the law
but here you've got people detained on
immigration
related charges isn't that a lot like
the skinner case
where the supreme court said this is
illegal
well they said it was illegal if it's
not properly applied so
you know look i think that to your point
it is rocky but as long as it's applied
equally
to all white collar immigration
violators whomever
then it is legal and it's not violating
the equal protection clause
the law may be shocking and it may
change depending on where this case goes
through the courts
and coming up next here on law and crime
daily 39 children
and minors rescued from the streets from
abductors
some of the victims sex trafficked we go
inside the federal state and local
operation which brought them home
in just a moment
[Music]
let's pause now to check in with chief
investigative correspondent brian ross
with what he's digging into this week on
the lawn crime network
thanks erin coming up this week on brian
ross investigates
the white house as conspiracy central
why the president continues to push
an unfounded baseless rumor that joe
scarborough the tv host and former
congressman
killed an aide when he was in congress
some 20 years ago
the president won't let up the second
question was about your tweets about the
the woman who died who you're
suggesting that joe scarborough was
responsible
yeah a lot of people suggest that and uh
hopefully someday people are going to
find out certainly a very suspicious
situation very sad we'll talk with mike
isikoff the chief investigative
correspondent yahoo news
why do americans so love conspiracy
theories and how
and whether should they be put to rest
that's coming up this week
on brian ross investigates on the law
and crime network
erin thanks brian law enforcement
officers have recovered some 72
missing children this summer in
operations nationwide
some of the children were runaways some
were trafficked for sex
the operation began with the recovery of
39 miners in the state of georgia
the director of the georgia bureau of
investigation takes us
inside that operation this was a
project that was operation that was
initially
started by the united states marshal
service here in georgia we really
emphasize partnerships where
federal state and local folks work
together on the law enforcement level
and that this is just
one of the best examples i've seen of it
in our state in a long time
the u.s marshals service reached out to
us
advised that they would be working this
operation gone but not forgotten they
had
65 active critically missing children
cases that they were working
ask us to join with them to partner we
did that process and thankfully we were
able to to close
39 of those cases by recovery it was
just a
great time for law enforcement something
i'm very very proud of here in georgia
who were the children you recovered can
you describe some of the cases for
us certainly i think you have to go back
a little bit to the beginning and
understand
how we define a critically missing child
some of those
are are literally ones who who are
runaways
some are abductions either family
abductions or non-family abductions so
that's the base we start out where we
have uh confirmed reports of children
missing
and so we key in on those 65 cases and
then
as we begin working them we discovered
that 39 of them we believed would
were actually solvable and fixable the
youngest one we recovered was three
years old
that was a situation where he had been
abducted by his biological father who
who had been accused previously of some
sexual misconduct with a 12 year old and
so
we were certainly very keen on finding
that child that was the youngest we
found
i i think something was very interesting
to me as a director of the gbi
one of our commitments here is to fight
human trafficking and 15 of these young
victims
we believe were human sex trafficking
victims and so
we were so thankful to find them as well
so it ran the gamut literally from three
years old
on up the sex trafficking victims the
director tells us we're brought
to a special center for treatment and
when we come back
learn where the children were found and
what motivates rescuing agents
to go into harm's way at times to find
them we'll be right back
on lawn crime daily
[Music]
the director of the georgia bureau of
investigation tells us that some of the
39 children his agency and others
recently rescued
were abducted by relatives others he
said were literally snatched off the
streets
by strangers the investigation that
brought them home used new techniques
and old ones we're sending out a number
of agents from not only the gbi and the
united states marshall services
but other federal agencies and local
departments as well and the locals are
so crucial
and critical to one of these operations
because they know the area they know the
homes
they know the streets they know where to
go when we
gather this intelligence a good number
of this is just just
plain old-fashioned law enforcement
where you're
knocking on a door you're talking to
individuals you
utilize every tool available to us and
some of those tools are old
did some of this then also move into new
technology cell phones facebook
and how did that part of the
investigation work you know it's it's i
tell folks now that
you know years ago when i was a young
cop one of the first things you do when
you get to a scene
is you canvas a neighborhood you try to
find out what's going on and that's
certainly still important but nowadays
with technology
being what it is you know one of the
first things we do is we start
collecting cell phones we start
gathering social
media information and so that's what we
we use is
extremely important tool not only in
this operation but in any operation that
law enforcement does now
what attracts some of your agents to
this sort of work
you know that's a great question i often
ask my my agents who work in
our human trafficking unit and our child
exploitation unit
why they do what they do and and i will
tell you categorically
it is a passion it is a proverbial
calling for these agents
uh to to rescue children to to pull them
out of
terrible circumstances to uh to to stop
child pornography to arrest an
individual who was hurt or molested a
child
it is a passionate calling for these
individuals and
i think it was the director of the
united states marshall service who said
you know we can collect fugitives and
find fugitives all day
but finding one missing child is more
important than collecting a thousand
fugitives around this country and so
i think that's the backbone and the
drive and the emphasis behind this
particular operation
and joining us now is georgia juvenile
court judge ashley wilcott judge
welcome back again to the broadcast the
gbi director told us this operation was
important because the pandemic forced
many people to stay home and that
ultimately meant the safety net
that oftentimes protects children such
as neighbors and teachers and whatnot
just simply wasn't
there i agree with that erin and the
reason is this because you have fewer
eyes on these children so we know
they're people who are mandatory
reporters people that see things
on children about children that they
report anonymously and that doesn't
happen when children
are in their home and people aren't
laying eyes on them
some of the children are home with
proper parents now
what happens to the others that were
rescued now that they're in the state
system
sure great question so erin what happens
is those who have either suffered abuse
to neglect
or are going to be returning to a home
where there's abuse to neglect
instead go into the foster care system
now the good news is
if they are unable to return to a safe
home that can provide
treatment for them the foster care
system is set up to provide those
services that these
very traumatized abused children are
going to need
federal state and local collaboration
was successful
in this case so from a policy standpoint
should that sort of collaboration happen
again oh yes absolutely it needs to
because the reality is there and there
are 250 missing children reported
missing children
in georgia in 2019 nationwide there are
over 450
000 missing children so while georgia's
doing well and fighting this
there are children out there that still
need to be found and still need to be
rescued
and what for the defendants judge
wilcott what sort of charges might they
be facing
and how might they be moving through the
system sure
lots of different charges so they're not
only facing potentially child abuse
child neglect but also things like
kidnapping aggravated assault they
are going to be facing trafficking
charges and there could be federal
charges depending on how much of a rico
or
a conspiracy there is between the
different defendants
judge ashley wilcott thanks a lot for
joining us here on law and crime daily
let's bring terry austin and brian
buckmeyer back in here for discussion to
round out this case
so bottom line here terry what started
in
georgia was eventually done elsewhere
with very similar successful results
well that's right and it's a good thing
too i know that they had some efforts in
indiana and other states but the good
news here
is that they're all coordinating with
federal and that makes sure
that they can find these children
particularly if they are taken
across state lines and they're also
pursuing the defendants too
and getting them off the street there
have been a number of arrests in that
regard
across state lines they usually trigger
federal charges brian let's let's get
into some nitty gritty here
some of this data involved
cell phones and whatnot that touches on
a constitutional rights area that can
get pretty tricky
absolutely let's begin by starting this
the officers and agents will stop
calling that they're heroes okay what
they did was amazing
however the tools that they use to find
these individuals
have to be aligned with the fourth
amendment rights of privacy
to ensure that these are only used
against those who need them
to be found and caught for certain
crimes but to ensure that innocent
people aren't trapped up in the same
woes that might happen when you go
against the fourth amendment
and the bottom line brian if you want to
make sure you're not going to get into
fourth amendment trouble you go get a
warrant
exactly warrantless searches are going
to be an issue here when you're looking
into the phone
to be able to track a person's position
i mean every day we have our cell phones
we have our
apple watches we're so connected we got
to make sure we don't trample on certain
rights
to find those that we're actually
looking for let's hope this
investigation was buttoned up
brian terry great discussion again here
on law and crime daily we'll see those
of you watching along with us back here
next time
[Music]
you